and II good morning thanks for joining
us is Justin fields transferring from
Georgia I would think so his name
appeared in the NCAA's transfer portal
last night so that means any school that
wants to recruit him now can contact him
and my guess is there will be a lot of
schools contact Justin fields because a
lot of schools one out of high school he
signed with Georgia
even though Jake from was in the middle
of leaving Georgia to an SEC title in
the national title game as a true
freshman and it didn't quite end up the
way Justin Fields wanted and now he's
probably gonna go to one of those
schools that probably will give him the
chance to start right away
all right there's an ugly backdrop to
this as well that might be part of his
rationale for transferring and being
allowed to play right away
give me a background story on Justin my
guess is that the reason for the
transfer is playing time but and I feel
like I come on your show and have to
explain all these really Byzantine nc8
that's super boring but there's a
basically they are they've changed the
way that they handle waivers for
undergraduates to transfer because
there's any transfer you're supposed to
sit out a year if you haven't already
graduated but if something happened that
is outside the athletes control that
affects his health safety or well-being
they're supposed to grant the waiver
well there was an incident during the
Georgia Tennessee game on September 29th
where a Georgia baseball player was
overheard in the stands yelling put the
N word in except he actually said the
word and he was referring to justice
fields this got investigated by Georgia
the guy was kicked off the baseball team
so there's it's thoroughly documented
and so if Justin shields wants to say
this is why I'm transferring there is no
way the NCAA from PR standpoint can deny
that waiver he's going to be able to
play next year what are the likely
destinations for him I know that you
said there gonna be a lot of schools
that are gonna be you know opening their
doors here but I immediately thought of
Ohio State if if you're good you know I
thought Joey Haskins is probably going
pro I'm not sure they're convinced Tate
Martell is the answer there so there's a
really good chance that that
that's where he had uh Oklahoma would be
another one caller Murray's not coming
back so but if you use that incident as
a reason I don't know that you can get a
waiver she'd go to the school that has
another high-profile incident like that
with the SAE fraternity video from a few
years ago so that would be a little odd
hmm
Florida State could be one that there's
a lot of options because so many schools
wanted this guy at high school
what about jaylen hurts any chance that
he transfers well I think there's a
chance I was surprised he didn't do it
this year but it certainly worked out
for him but he has now graduated from
Alabama he can go somewhere and play
right away if he wants to I think but
with him I think we're gonna have to see
what happens throughout the rest of the
playoffs because you know we don't know
if - we're talking about always gonna be
fully healthy we don't know Jalen's
gonna have to come in again and do it in
the SEC championship game so I think
that's a wait-and-see but you know if if
tongue of our law is healthy plays the
whole playoff there's a real good chance
Jalen Hurd's does go somewhere else and
you know Oklahoma would be another good
option for him
it's Justin Herbert left Oregon to go
pro that would be a good option TCU is
open that's in his home state so I think
there's there's quite a few spots
you always pick out some great names on
the recruiting trail
didn't you have kobe buffalo meat was
that a was that a player who got a
player that's an illinois buffalo meat
is is awesome and i got some good ones
this year - it's uh
I like that medium rare movement so far
what yeah we got a steel chamber signing
with Ohio State he's gonna either either
super bunch of touchdowns or he'll open
his own detective agency catering only
to the sexiest clients I'm like the
Maverick McIver is a quarterback at
Texas Tech and storm duck in the upset
of the century
cornerback storm duck is not going to
organ if you wanted North Carolina Wow
give me the top quarterbacks where
they're going top three
it's interesting because this is not a
year like last year where it was Trevor
Lawrence and and Justin fields and
everybody else several arts
who's playing at Clemson now is it the
there really isn't a guy that everybody
thinks okay this is the guy so it's it's
hard to say you know who are the top
three they maybe I'm ranked on the
ranking sites but there's nobody who's
like an obvious hey this guy's gonna
come in and be a star hmm okay so it
will be interesting Wisconsin has a guy
named Graham mercs coming in from Kansas
that I think that the recruits are very
high on him and think he could actually
push Alex Hornibrook fairly early which
would be really interesting because they
they still have Jonathan Taylor at
Wisconsin that offense could be could be
pretty interesting if they have a
quarterback good enough to push the
three-year starter what about Michigan
well they you know they like the guys
they signed last year they got a guy on
out of Orlando named Jill Hill who has a
great arm wound up being the backup
after Dylan McCaffrey got hurt so I
think probably what you're gonna see is
and whatever happens with Shea Patterson
will see but I don't know that say
Patterson is ready to go pro yet so I
would think he's back and then you've
also had McCaffrey Milton it's a pretty
good group to choose from for Jim
Harbaugh and this is a Christian
McCaffrey's brother Dylan yes yep and he
he was the backup but he got hurt this
year and they had to use Milton who was
a true freshman toward the end is this -
I have a brother
the do does another Talia he is going to
to Alabama remember the family moved
from Hawaii to alabaster Alabama and the
little bro has been lighting it up in
the state of Alabama and looks like he's
gonna follow to his footsteps
good stuff Andy I know you got a busy
day thanks for spending some time with
us all right that's Andy staples Sports
Illustrated senior college football
writer for more Dan Patrick show to the
audio
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]